>> MARKS: My name is Mano Marks. I'm a developer
advocate at Google. That means this is my
job. I get to come out and talk to developers
around the world who are working with our--our
mapping APIs. And--so I'm really glad to be
here. I noticed that BootCamp was built as
this small and intimate gathering compare
to Google I/O. And I also noticed that the--there's
like a thousand people here. So I don't know
how small and intimate everything is, but
I hope you guys have been having a good time
today. I am going to talk about a number of
things related to mobile development. So first
of all, how many of you have a mobile device?
Okay. So this is a little developer advocate,
right, you get everybody raising their hands
at the beginning. Everybody feels like they're
participating in something, it's a little
trick they teach you. The other trick is you
let people in on your tricks, makes me feel
included. But really I don't care about the
tricks. I just want to show you what's cool
about mobile devices. So how many of you have
written an application using some form of
the Google Maps API and some application?
Okay. That's it. That's a good number. That's
probably about two-thirds, it's an interesting
number. What I'm going to talk to you about
here, you know, you can obviously see what
I've written up here. But the first thing
we're going to talk about is what is different
about mobile AP--mobile mapping. Why is this
a different kind of talk than your basic--how
to get started with Google Maps on X platform.
And we're going to talk about the different
kinds of options here. Now they are multiple
options. You can develop using native applications,
native APIs. You can develop using our JavaScript
API. You can do a combination of the two.
You can use our static maps API. I'm going
to go through all these different options
and talk about why they are the same--why
they're different and what the different advantages
are of each. At the end, I'm actually going
to go through and do a comparison feature
by feature which--what the major features
are and what you have on the different platforms.
And you'll see from that why I recommend the
JavaScript API. And then finally I'm going
to talk about some optimizations that you
can use to make your maps faster. Okay. So
what is difference about--about mobile? There's
a lot of different things obviously about
mobile. If you take a look at the mobile devices
that you have in your--on your person right
now, you've got phones, you've got tablets,
you've got--what else you got, laptops, these
are--these are different things that you're
using, you're carrying around with you. And
they have very different screen sizes, very
different form factors. So this is a lot smaller
than a Motorola Zoom and it's shaped differently,
it's got different aspect ratios and that
sort of thing. This is also carrying around
with it connections, innate connections that
it has two networkings; this has WiFi on it
and it's got 3G and 2G, you know, it's got
slower speed connections for edge networks.
It's got a lot of different kinds of connections
and your different devices have different
connections depending on where they're physically
located with what kind of device they are,
what networks they are, what SIM cards you
have in them, that sort of thing. So these
are--these are things you have to take into
account. And a piece of that is what I'm going
to--I'm going to generically refer to connections
as latency. So this issue of latency is like
how long does it take for your map to actually
display in--to your user? You also have to
take into account things like user interface.
What kind of interface interactions you get
on a device. So mobile devices are new because
you interact with them with your fingers not
with a keyboard, right? So there's a lot of
different kinds of interactions and different
devices will actually pass different connections
to browsers than they will to native applications
and there's some things to think about there.
I'm going to do some--I'm going to be mentioning
that as we go along and also doing some demos.
These devices services, so these--these--these
is where you actually get a lot more power
out of something like this than you don out
of your laptop. You have a GPS device in this,
I mean, think about a few years ago, five
years ago, you've been carrying around a GPS
in your pocket with, you know, just in your
phone that was--that would've been pretty
incredible. So you're getting that. You're
getting things like compass, you get contacts,
you get all these sort of different kind of
services that aren't necessarily available
in a browser-based application. You also use--obviously
have a different operating systems. You've
got Android devices, Samsung has its own Bada
interface, got the iOS devices. You've got
a lot of different kinds of things coming
down the line that have different kinds of
operating systems. And each one of them has
different--different programming languages
associated with them in different ways in
which you--you cope. And the--the traditional
solution on computers to solve that problem
was Flash, because Flash is installed on some
huge percentage of computers like 90 some
percent, 99% or something like that. But not
on mobile devices, in fact only--of the major
devices out there, I believe only Android
devices support Flash, so obviously, the iOS
you can't use Flash APIs to connect to them.
All right. So--this was the landscape two
years ago when I first gave this kind of talk.
When we first introduced the Google Maps API
version three, we had a fairly simple way
to explain what you did with the different--what
you could do with the different devices. And
you see there that's a G1, that's the first
Android device and this is the first iPhone,
on the far, your left there, you have--I just
put up a Nokia phone, it's like a feature
phone, it's got a basic browser in it. But
you don't have access to Google Maps through
any sort of other programming interface so
using the basic browser with no JavaScript
you need to do something like the Static Maps
API. Then you have Native APIs that are available
in iOS and Android so that is if you're an
Android developer, you use MapView, if you're
an iOS developer you use Map Kit. And our
suggestion was to use the JavaScript API which
could be used on both of those. But the situations
changed a little bit in the Intra. You've
got a wider variety of devices now, some of
which are coming along in their smart phones
but don't--a few of them which don't even
use either Android or iOS like the Samsung
Bada. And--and you got these powerful tablets
coming out that have also these very different
interfaces, they have different ways in which
people use them, interact with them, carry
them around. So these are just all the kinds
of things--I like to put this up towards the
beginning to remind you sort of what work--what
we're talking about--we're not talking about
just a map on your phone and because I'm with
Google, we're not just talking about, you
know, an Android device or a few Android devices.
But actually there are, you know, dozens of
Android devices on the market and many tablets
coming down the line. Okay. So, let's get
back to latency for a minute. I like to--to
sort of highlight this. Now, there are basically
two kinds of latency. And remember again,
latency, I'm basically talking about the speed
in which something loads--application loads.
There's two kinds of latency. One is the actual
latency. The time it takes to load a page
or an application with a--on your device,
and then there's the user-perceived latency
which is how long the user thinks it actually
takes. And you want to reduce both of these.
Obviously, the first helps with the second
but there are tricks that you can do that
help with the second while you're--while you're
trying to help with the first. So let me give
you an example. And I give you--this is an
example because, one, we like to talk about
our JavaScript Maps API but two, because these
are techniques that, on the next slide, I
will show you that you can also use yourself.
And--before I get too far into this, let mention,
how many--you're all going to Google I/O,
right? Okay, there's a talk, I think it's
tomorrow, it's called Speedy Maps. And the
Speedy Maps talk will go into greater detail
on a lot of the--the pieces that I'm going
to discuss now. But if you can't get to it,
I'm going to--I'm going to go into some detail
just talking about--what but that they--these
will be actual engineers on the--JavaScript
Maps API who can tell you--you know, in great
detail how you can, you can speed up your
map. But here's what we did, when we switched
from version two to version three of the Google
Maps API. We totally rewrote it. And we did
it, you know, in such a way that it would
be optimized from mobile devices because we
knew that that was the main way in which people
are going to start interacting with our maps.
So, the first thing you do is you load only
the code that is necessary. Version two of
the API--the map, the central map object knew
about everything. If you want to put a marker
on a map, you said, you know, oh, take the
map and put a marker on it at this location.
Now if you just want to put a map, the map
knows nothing about markers. All it does is
it downloads some stubby interfaces so that
you can--so that you can then load down code
that you actually need when you need it. So,
if you need to load a code for a map and a
marker, it only loads the code for the map
and the marker. If you want--need to load
driving directions, it loads that code as
well. But only the code that you actually
need which is different from version two of
the API, reducing the file size, reducing
the number of files going down the line. Another
thing we did was we loaded--we load a static
map first. It's the fist thing we do, we put
in a static map, that looks like your map.
Static map is just an image a straight up,
you know, single image of your map with, you
know, what ever the basic markers on beforehand.
And the reason we do this is that the user
sees something happening, reducing that user
perception of something going on. People are--are
more forgiving if they can see an actual map.
They can go, oh, I can see that. They may
try and interact with it and quite can't do
it yet but that functionality then gets loaded
behind it and the static map then goes away
and people can interact with them. So, load
the static map first. So, the hint there is
when you're doing something in a mobile application,
load something that shows up before, while
you're doing something to give people something
to do. And then the other one, and this one
actually surprises quite a bit, is package
your downloads together. The greatest determinant
actually of how long some thing took to load
with how many files were downloaded. It's
a much greater determinant than the actual
size of the downloads. If you could--if you
downloaded four 250 megabyte or sorry 250
kilobyte files, instead of one--one megabyte
file--what or a thousand kilobyte file. You--you
would--the four files would download a lot
slower than the one file. This is because
the browser does things sequential, right?
So, if you package it all up together, you
load one--you load it once. And you can do
these things yourself, right? Or if you're
writing JavaScript or you're writing code,
or you're making server calls, package things
together in course downloads. These are things
you can do to--to help optimize your maps.
Load the static map first, load only the code
that you need to load to do the objects you--the
things you need to do, and there's a couple
of other things that we suggest and I'm going
to talk more about this one later. The use
[INDISTINCT] clickable image overlays to--for
larger datasets and--I mean, talk a lot more
about that but this is a--this is one of the
key optimizations that you can use for mobile
devices. Okay, so that's the--that's the basics
of like what's different and like the kinds
of things that you have to be worried about
more from mobile devices that you do for--for
desktop devices. So, development options;
just to review this again, native applications,
we're going to be talking about, if you want
to write native a--a Google map in native
code, your two options are, MapKit on iOS
and map view on Android. For our JavaScript
maps API, you can use it in any web kit enabled
browser. I've got a--a list there. There's
a list in the documentation. It's bigger than
iOS and--and Android. And then, for non-JavaScript
browsers, the static maps API. Okay. So let's
talk a little bit about the advantages and
disadvantages of native apps. And I'm trying
not to wander too far over here because I
think that's bad for the video. Sorry, to
the videographer. I tend to wander a lot when
I'm talking because I get excited. Also I've
had a little caffeine so, you know. Things
are--things are exciting. Okay, so MapKit.
Map kit on iOS is an actual Android product.
Sorry, an Apple product. It says Google Maps
and may do use our services to do it. I just
need to point this out. We don't actually
provide support for it because it's--it's
technically actually an Apple product. It
still gives you a Google Map. You get the
Google--they're very nice map tiles that we
provide and a bunch of other things. We provided
them with the version of Google Maps from
Mobile and they then went and customized that
for their--their own use. On Android, you
use Map view which is something provided directly
by Google. So the advantage of these two as
the case is that they are native code. They're
more–they can be–-therefore more easily
integrated with the native application. If
you are writing an Android app, you're writing
an iPhone App, you can directly integrate
these into your application and it's the one
programming language, right. You know in Android,
it's JavaScript or C or whatever you're going
to–-you're using to write your Apps there
and it's objective C for iOS. And the advantage
of integration is you don't have to learn
JavaScript or something other to–-other
language to load something. There's a bit
lower latency because when somebody actually
downloads the App, once it's actually downloaded
then you've got native writing on their phone
that or their device that code, right so they
don't have to go and reload it down whenever
they load a page. This discrepancy is actually
starting to lessen some as the JavaScript
map API gets to be more powerful or faster
but they're still–-they're still some latency
there. You get full user interface support,
so all the interfaces that are custom for
that device are supported natively in that
application. So what do I mean by that? So,
sorry, if you do pinch to zoom for instance
on a Android device, you will get–you will
get pinch to zoom in your map view, so somebody
can just you know, literally pinch on the–-on
the device. That is not passed through to
the Android browsers and I believe it is passed
through to the iPhone browsers so you get
this--in native code, you get access to all
those kinds of events that any application
can take advantage of. Let's get another thing
which is discoverability, right? You want
to put your application in the Android market
place, you want to put your application in
the Apple–-in the Apple store than in the
App store then you get–-people can find
it there. Of course, you're competing with
all the other devices–-the other applications
that are out there but you know, it's not
web search, right, so it's a different kind
of discoverability and people are still using
that as one of the main ways in which they
find out what Apps to use. On the other hand,
you do have to go through the approvals process
for these different platforms to get your
applications out there. That's okay. You want–-I
should try good dramatic pose for the photographer,
that's in the video [INDISTINCT] there's a
photographer down there. I'll try and do it
naturally. Okay, so what are some of the other
points? If you want to write an application
that works on both Android and iPhone though,
that means that you're recoding that map for
every platform that you're doing, right. So
you're writing an iPhone application, you're
writing an Android application blah, blah,
blah. It's extra work and when you want to
update that application, you have to update
the entire application where you have to do
an update that somebody has to then download
through the market place, through the Apps
store which means that it's going to happen
less frequently and your users, your map,
that map portion of your application is going
to be different on the different ones. And
finally, there are many fewer features within
the native APIs than within the JavaScript
API. That's because for the JavaScript API,
that's all we're doing is making new features
and making it better. Okay, so browser based
APIs, let's talk about the differences there.
So I got a list here on the Android, iOS,
Samsung, Dolfin, the Blackberry 6, these are–-these
are platforms that apparently supported by
the JavaScript maps API on different–-on
different browser. And you do get access to
some phone--native phone features particularly
geolocation which seems to be, you know, one
of the primary ones for mapping applications.
You can access other HTML 5 features like
local storage and all that sort of thing depending
on the device and the availability of those
features. I call this the write once, tweak
everywhere because of course, you're going
to have different devices, have different
screen sizes and different UI constraints.
You don't get access to all of those UI features
as I mentioned in Android, currently, you
don't get access to that pinch to zoom kind
of functionality. So that's something top
just take in into consideration. It also looks
slightly different, right? Both map view and
MapKit are designed to look like native applications,
the interfaces and look like, you know, an
Android or iPhone application. The browser
application doesn't mimic those UI features
in quite the same way. But then-–the one
of the key things that I think of that's really
different about this is that you get really
rapid deployment and development of the application.
JavaScript and HTML are very simple and you
can push it out to your server? You don't
have to update your application, you just
have app–-you know, you just have people
load a new version of it. You know, downside
is you don't get the discoverability, the
App store market place discoverability but
you do get–-you do get access to–-you
don't have to do there approvals, sorry, that's
what I was trying to get at. Okay, so let's
just look at the basic code. This is your
basic code for creating a browser based application.
You'll see here I don't know probably in the
video you won't be able to actually see my
red dot on the screen but you'll see here
I've got–-this is the loader so you're loading
this script tag maps.google.com/maps/api/js
and I've added this parameter sensory equals
true. We always ask the people to add a sensor
parameter because our data providers require
it. If you're using the JPS or something in
the device to say, here's where this person
is located then we ask that you add this sensor
equals true otherwise the sensor equals false.
That does not give you any benefits of the
sensor itself--they–-there are other ways
to get access to that. I just always mention
that. Then you set a variety of options in
this case you're just setting the zoom level,
higher numbers mean you're more zoomed in,
lower numbers are farther out. And then the
map type, so in this case, I'm setting it
to a road map. And then I create the map and
basically just say assign it to this div on
in the HTML, past it the options that I declare
there and you've got a map and that's it.
The basics of doing HTML 5 geolocation are
right here, this is, you can just ask if this
object exists "(navigator.geolocation)." And
what it will say, it will return to you as
whether or not that's true, that object exist.
If it exists, then you do something with it.
And this is the very basics of doing something
with it, "navigator.geolocation.getCurrentPosition,"
says, you know, "Okay, you have the object
now. Find me that position. And when you do,
you pass this function here and you do something
with it, right?" And in this case, this code
will actually say, "Okay, set the center of
the map to that location." There are many
different things you can do here. One thing
I want to point out is when you do all this,
when you put it in this "navigator.geolocation"
when the user loads it, the browser will ask
the user. "Is it okay for me to share your
location with this application?" And it'll
be just the first time that they load that
application. And actually I'd like to switch
over to the Elmo if I could. So, I've got
here a Motorola zoom. I'm going to apologize;
the focus doesn't seem to be working very
well on the Elmo. This is actually really
nice on the Motorola zoom. But you'll see
here that I've already given it my permission
to access my location for this site. So, what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to zoom
in a little bit. You'll see it actually did
a pretty good job of finding where we are.
Well, I wish you could really see that. But
this is--trust me, this is approximately where
we are. Sorry, the projector's not doing a
great job of picking that up. You'll notice
there something else here that I put this
gray circle around it. Now, I did that because
geolocation actually gives you something a
little bit more interesting which is, it tells
you how accurate it thinks that location is.
Tells you, you know, all you have to do is
say, on the position, give me the accuracy.
And it'll tell you within how many meters
it thinks it has it. Now it's up to the device
to figure out how to give you that information.
You can also ask it interesting things like,
how old is this position? How many seconds
ago was this position taken? And things like,
are you using coarse or fine grain accuracy?
Basically, is this assisted GPS or is it just
WiFi based geolocation? These are different
questions that the device figures out how
to answer and then passes you back that information.
So, you can get some really rich interesting
information just from the basic HTML5 spec.
Now, people always ask me, what's the support
for the maps API for geolocation? And I always
say, you don't need it, it's in the HTML5
spec. Okay, so let's switch back to the computer.
So, I want to talk about one other option
for smart phone development and that's the
hybrid application. That is basically a native
application that runs a browser within it.
So, this is basically, you create this native
application that creates a shell around your
map using UI WebView and iOS and WebView in
an Android device. This gives you some of
the advantages and all of the disadvantages
of both systems, almost all. I call it the
worst of both worlds and also the best of
both worlds. But, you know, mostly what people
hear is the worst. You have decent UI integration,
and, you know, you get to discover ability
on a variety of platforms both on WebSearch
and in the market place. But you still have
to write these native applications. This is
currently our suggested method for most developers
because most developers are wanting to learn
the different platforms as well. But, you
know, your mileage may vary. The Google I/O
application that you may have downloaded from
the market place uses this method for the
map. I may be running a little bit out of
time. So, I'm not going to go into great telling
the code but these slides will be published.
There's also an article on Maps API documentation
about how to do this. But basically, you know,
you have to do a WebView layout. You have
to give permissions to Internet access of
course for the--for your hybrid application.
And if you want to get access to location
data, you have to give permissions for--for
coarse and fine grain location. And then this
is the basic code, you basically have to create
a web map activity, and set up your WebView,
and then you just load the URL. So, it's actually,
you know, it's a bit more involved in that
particularly if you want to expose some other
native services like contacts or geolocations
to the device, oh sorry, to your JavaScript
page. But this is your basics for setting
up the code. Okay, so let's talk quickly about
feature phones. How many of you have feature
phones that is non smartphones? Okay not very
many. But most people in the world do, right?
Most people in the world have feature phones.
And for many people that's the sole way in
which they access the Internet. Now, what
I mean here is, say you have a dumb browser
and I don't mean that in a highly pejorative
way, but a little pejorative. That is, that
it can't really handle full JavaScript support
or they might, this is also an option for
you when you're operating in very low bandwidth
environments. Using our stem--static maps
API, you can get a very light weight map server.
No, it's non-interactive, it's just an image,
right? You specify things like, you know,
how big you want it, what color of the markers
are, that sort of thing. It's fairly fully
featured except that it's again non-interactive
but it's fast. And that's the key here. Very
small lightweight tiles. And this is basically
what it looks like. It's just a URL, right?
And within that URL, up to 2,048 characters,
you can specify a map and you get a map back.
And here I specified things like Brooklyn
Bridge, New York, New York. So, you're doing
a little of bit of geolocation. You can actually
say, "Center it on a, you know, an address
rather than centering it on a specific geolocation."
You know, zoom level size, the map type. You
know, satellite or road map or whatever. And
then I'm actually specifying markers at different
locations and different colors for the markers.
You can even do things like specify custom
marker URLs. So, if you have something that's
for your application that you use, you can
specify those custom markers. You can add
in poly lines, you can add in polygons, you
can do really interesting but non-interactive
stuff. And we're turned back a very fast,
lightweight application. Okay, so let's go
through some of the feature of comparisons
here. I've got two slides of this and the
bottom line is that first column, the JavaScripts
maps API has tons of features that are not
in any of the other--the other APIs. You know,
everybody does the basics except you'll notice
one here geocodings seem to actually be missing
from the MapKit. Geocoding is the process
of taking an address and turning it into latitude
and longitude. So that's, you know, their
choice. They chose not to expose that through
MapKit. But you can do interesting things
like this KML/GeoRSS Layers, driving directions,
traffic, circles and rectangles, custom overlays,
image types, custom map types, fusion tables
integration. The list is actually longer than
this. Styled Maps. That's another fun one.
The list is actually longer than this. I just
didn't feel like going on for slide-after-slide
of the Javascript features. So there is one
interesting data point right here, which is
navigation. So the Android devices actually
allow to do this thing, which is launching
things as an intent. How many of you are Android
developers? Okay. So you can--you know, other
applications can expose an interface that
you can say, "Just launch this application."
It's not really an API. It's just, you know,
pass me some information and I will--I will
give them--give you access to this application
and you can launch it. Navigation, which is
that turn-by-turn directions that you can
get on Android phones is exposed through the--as
an intent in Android devices and that is the
only platform that that's available on. So
I do want to, like, fess up. That is--that
is the case. That's some optimization. But
I want to go and do another couple of demos
here for you. So if we can get back to the--to
the Elmo. We could go back to the Elmo, please.
Okay. So, I showed you this geolocation. Let's
take a look at this here. This is a little
bit harder to see because this is--this is
not a fantastic presentation. But if you were
asked to see it on the actual device, this
is nicer. This is Google Map and you'll see
it's actually in black-and-white. I deliberately
optimized this map to take away something;
take away a lot of things from this map. And
one of the things I took away was color. So
I changed everything to black-and-white and
I took away most of the points of interest,
and I took away all the roads. I left on the
transit lines. This is actually in Japan.
And I chose that because Japan is very dense
in the map. And this is what the map looks
like normally. Now, that's a lot of information
that's missing in my Styled Map. Go back to
this same location, the Styled Map. Now the
reason I did that, by the way, is to de-clutter
the map. Now, on this huge screen that we've
got here, you know, you see a lot information
and that's generally considered to be good.
But what if you're doing it on your phone?
And where did my phone go? There's my phone.
What if you're doing it on something this
size? If you have all that information, you--you're
exposing the user to looking at all that information
and trying to parse through it. If you can
de-clutter your map, then, you know, that's
an optimization that you can use to make a
better user interface for your user. You can
also do things like change the color so that
it matches your--the color scheme of your
website or something else, you know; some
for aesthetic reasons. And I also wanted to
point out this. So again, usually, a lot cooler
in--if you view this site actually in--on
your device, this looks a lot sharper. But
this is a Google Street View. And, you know,
you see, if you move around in Street View--my
connection is pretty slow right at the moment.
But generally, when you're moving around in
Street View, you see streets, right? So one
thing we add, which is only available in the
Javascript, Maps API is this custom Street
View. So this is the indoor--this is the indoor
offices of the Sydney office. This is a Maps
API site and they basically just open one
panoramic photo and put it into this Maps
API site. And you'll see that it's actually
integrated with the controls so I can go back
out to the road and view the road. So Street
View available to you through the Javascript
Maps API and it served up using HTML 5 so
you get to see it on any browser. We did that
deliberately because Flash wasn't supported
on many mobile devices. Okay. I want to talk
about another kind of optimization. And this
is kind of a two parter. So, you may remember
back at the beginning, I talked about doing
clickable raster overlays to show large amounts
of data. Now this is--this is a Maps API application
running on--just on my own website and it's
using the Fusion Table Layer. Now what Fusion
Tables is, is it's--how many of you have used
Fusion Tables or know what it is? Not very
many. Okay. So Google Fusion Tables is a way
for you to upload large amounts of what we
call vector data that is, you know, tabular
data. Spreadsheets, databases, yes, CSP files
and we--and KML files, and put them--store
them on Google servers and then query them
using Google's--using an API or directly into
the Google Maps API. And then what happens
is Google will render these as map tiles.
So this is not rendered as Javascript objects
within the browser. It's rendered as a single
image tile or actually multiple images tiled
the same way we do the tiling for the map
itself. So notice when I move the map here
like this, you'll see--you will see different--if
I move it in places I haven't actually been
to see that part of the map will not be exposed
and then it will--it will come in. You see
there where it's drawing Alaska there. The
idea here is that you take in it--you take
an image to represent all your markers and
all your features and it's a lot smaller than
creating Javascript objects for every marker
or feature. There's a talk on fusion tables.
I believe it's tomorrow. And James Miguel
who did--who's doing that did some tests.
I'm going to preview this for you. He took
100,000 markers on a--on high end Mac Pro
using Chrome. So the best, you know, environment
for rending that. Rendered it within the browser
and it took 34 seconds to render all those
markers. Now anything less than that set up
and probably the browser would have just choked
on it. Using Google Fusion Tables and rendering
it as these clickable overlays 100,0000 rendered
in three seconds and the map was actually
useable. So the other thing that happens when
you render 100,000 markers or any large number
of markers on to the map whenever you move
the map, the map has to move every--all the
overlays. Where as if you're doing it all
as one image then it--it happens more quickly.
So, again, more details in both the Speedy
Maps Talk and the Fusion Tables Talk. So within
JavaScript, and again, this is because of
the projector here, it's not rendering very
quickly. But let me--you can actually dynamically
interact with this layer through the query--through
the query object. So here I'm just using a
slider and what I'm doing is I'm taking--this
is a map of congressional districts in the
United States by population. And the color
code--the color of the polygon represents
the actual population. I'm doing a query which
is to hard up there but it's a SQL query,
right? So it's basic SQL query, SQL, saying
select the shape column, that is a column
that describes the congressional district
boundaries here and it says from--and it gives
a table ID and where, so these are just straight
up SQL. The median age of the total population,
that's one column, is greater than a certain
number, the number being generated by that--by
the slider when I click on the slider. So
in this case, these are all the places where
congressional districts have median population
greater than 40. You see there's a lot of
them in Florida. Okay. So if we could go back
to the laptop. Thank you. So optimizations,
create these clickable raster overlays. And
the--there's three methods of doing that using
Google. One is to use a Fusion Table. That
is currently the best way. You can also use
your own KML or GeoRSS files and create what's
called a KML Layer in there. We'll create
these highly optimized rasters for you. And
when you click on them, you can actually get
click events back. Cache your data and your
tiles locally, we have an article on documentation
that shows you some of the URLs that you can
use to cache the tiles. You can't access them
directly but if you just use the cache manifest
for performance purposes, you can cache those
tiles so that every time somebody goes back
somewhere they don't have to reload them.
Use your HTML5 features like local storage
and Geolocation. And compile your code. How
many of you are familiar with Closure, Google
Closure? Not many of you, okay. Open source
library for compiling JavaScript. You ever
go to a website and you're like "Oh, I just
want to view source." How many of you are
JavaScript developers? Okay. You go and you
view the source and you look at it and you
go, "Whoa, what, wait, what was that?" Because
you can't read it, right? It's just one big
block of compiled texts. That's because it's
gone through a compiler, a process that's
also known as minification. So the compiler
strips out all the human readable portions
of it and turns it into something that is
debts. Not readable but the browser can still
interact with it. This minified code is much
smaller so it's reducing your file size. Other
optimizations do--be flexible in your styling,
right? We already provide interactions so
if you go to our--if you go to a Maps API
site using the default user interface and
it's on a very small device, we'll give you
a smaller control. And if it's on a larger
device, we'll give you larger controls completely
dependent on the size of the div. But use
a flexible screen size, don't set, you know,
pixel bound--pixel sizes for your height and
weight but use percentages, you know, and
on a small device for your map, you probably
want to use 100%, takes up the whole screen.
And some people like to try and match the
native user interface. There's some CSS libraries
out there for actually matching the iOS screen
size, I'm sorry, screen representations. So
I've got links in here to a number of articles
and a video at the bottom for doing this kind
of optimizations and developing for mobile
devices using Google Maps API. This will be,
you know, I assumed this--I assumed this will
be published somewhere. This is our speaker
meter, so, you know, please give feedback
on the talk. I'd really like to know what
you guys think about it. It's just, you know
speakermeter.com/talks/mapping-mobile-devices
and these are the hash tags: # Geo and #iobootcamp,
if you want to tweet about this. So at this
point, I am now going to take questions and
what I'd appreciate is if you do--I want to
ask question if you can use the mic so that
it will get recorded on to video. So, thank
you. Sorry, I was staring right into the sun
there. Yes, go ahead.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> MARKS: Yes. For--the question is "For a
native Android App, I suggest that you use
WebView with a--with the JavaScript API."
The Android people might suggest something
different but this gives you a lot of different
advantages. Yes, next question.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> MARKS: Go ahead and I'll just repeat your
question.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> MARKS: Uh-huh.
>> MARKS: Yes. So you want to--you want to--let
me see if I--I'll repeat your question and
see if I make sure I'm getting this right.
You want to find all the pizza joints that
are within a certain radius, right? Yes, so
Google Fusion Tables would be able to do that
for you. So you upload your data to Fusion
Tables. You can upload it in a CSV file or
spreadsheet or KML file. Just have the GO
locations within it or you can have one column
that has the address--the address and use
that and GO code that column. And then in
the Maps API, you saw the thing I was showing
you with the census data, that's loading in
data from fusion tables with the fusion table
layer. And you can do three kinds of spatial
queries on fusion tables using that--using
an SQL syntax. The--you can do a radius search.
So you can say, "Give me everything within
x number of meters of this one point," and
what it'll do is it will give you an intersection.
So, if you're looking at polygons, it'll actually
show you polygons that intersect that radius
not just or wholly contained within it. You
can also do a bounding box. You can say, "Here's
a rectangle defined by two points. Give me
everything that intersects with that." You
can also do nearest neighbor. So you can say,
"Give me the 50 nearest points to this point,"
or, "The 50 nearest features to this particular
point." Yes?
>> You mentioned that the navigation data
is available only on the Android API.
>> MARKS: Right. And to be clear, it's not
navigation data. You're just launching the
navigation application directly using an intent.
>> Okay.
>> MARKS: So you don't get direct access to
navigation. All you're saying is, you know,
"Hey. We've loaded this up. Do you want to
view this in navigation and navigate directly
that?"
>> So is there an API to be able to--let's
say, to start address and address, give me
the KML, or give me some--give me the information
that makes the blue line that gets you from
here to there.
>> MARKS: Is there--is there a directions
API is what you are asking.
>> I think so.
>> MARKS: Yes. There is.
>> Okay.
>> MARKS: So when I say navigation, what I
mean is that turn by turn navigation that
reads out the directions and, kind of, moves--you
know, like you--animates your movement along
the map.
>> Got you. Yes. Yes.
>> MARKS: Yes. The JavaScript Maps API provides
driving directions. The Android MapView provides
driving directions. We have a web service
that you can pass to addresses or deal locations
too and say give me back driving directions.
And when you do that, it actually gives you
the--all the different steps there and that
allows you to draw that directly on your--on
your map or you can just use the JavaScript
API that will draw it from the map.
>> Okay. And it--is--will it could be back--I
mean I know--you know, the GO tag locations
of each the turns?
>> MARKS: Yes. So, the driving--the directions
API, you can query it to get the steps and--which
the steps contain the line segments.
>> Got you.
>> MARKS: Between each location. And also
the individual points that in which you do
the turn. And you can do things with that
like you can manipulate that, right? In the
driving directions and, let's say, you happen
to know that you have a--let's say, an amusement
park or a park or something and somebody is--you
can get--by the way, you know, walking and
bicycling directions as well. So, you can
say, "Okay. Drive to this location," and then
you can tack onto it and then go--you know,
go further using walking along this path that
I've defined myself."
>> Very good. Thank you.
>> MARKS: Sure.
>> Can you comment on Google Places and how
to translate a location latitude and longitude
into a business?
>> MARKS: Can I comment on Google Places and
how to translate a latitude/longitude into
business.
>> How do you get the real content?
>> MARKS: And the real content. So, last year
at Google I/O, we announced Google Places
API was going to be launched and it hasn't
yet been launched. So, unfortunately at this
point, there isn't. But I suggest that I/O
that you ask for Mitchell about the specifics
about that. We kept it in a very limited private
beta. We weren't ready to release it at that
point.
>> Are there other public sources that a person
might use?
>> MARKS: Are there other public sources for
Places APIs. Yes, there are. Facebook, Yelp,
a variety of Forsquare, simple GO, there's
a variety of other sources for Place data
as well.
>> Thank you.
>> MARKS: Hopefully we'll have the Places
API really soon.
>> What's your recommendations for writing
apps that need to use maps but offline? So,
you've got a tablet that's only WiFi or something
and therefore...
>> MARKS: Yes. So the question is offline
maps and what is my recommendation fro that.
I don't--I don't have a great recommendation
for that. And to be frank, I don't think anybody
really has a fantastic recommendation for
it. We are limited by our data providers to
not giving out the base vector data of our
maps. So, we can't give you all the information
about where all the roads are, for instance.
So that would be something that would be necessary
for doing that, for drawing your own maps.
If you can find that data and there are--there
are sources of data on this that are less
complete than ours like open street map or
a variety of other sources that will provide
those things. You certainly can. That's a
complex app that you can write yourself. And
there are some options in Android marketplace
I know for that--for offline maps. One thing
you can do is--if somebody is going to be
offline for a relatively short period of time,
you can cache in the mechanism that I described
before. You just use a cache manifest to cache
tiles. And that was approved last year at
I/O to say if you want to do something like
load a driving--load driving directions, and
then, in an offline div walk through all those
driving directions so it caches the tiles
that are necessary for that. So that when
somebody tries to go back to it, on your application,
but they're offline at the moment, then they
can still see the tiles. There's not a lot
of good answers to the offline mode at that
moment. You could also do that with the Static
Maps API. But just to emphasize, you can't
directly access those tiles from the cache.
You can just let the application re-access
that. Any more questions? Okay. Great. Well,
thanks so much and enjoy the rest of the conference.